-Welcome back to the show.
That's a hometown crowd
right here.
-Oh, my God, this is...
-Yeah, I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to know
about you guys growing up
because your
New York City brothers.
You're all brothers from New
York City. You grew up here.
And how long have you
been performing together?
I know you know
each other forever.
-Yes, we do.
-We started off street
performing
in Washington Square Park
in Central Park,
like 18 years ago.
And you were maybe seven?
-I was seven years old.
-Wow. Yeah.
Were you really?
-No, I actually was.
-You were seven years old.
-Seven years old.
-And how did you get into
busking? What would you do?
-So we just knew nobody
in the industry.
So we were like, "I guess this
is our in into the industry."
-Like, the funny thing was that
as we did it more,
we ended up making
a lot of money
and people --
when I say that to people,
they're like, "Wow,
you must have been really good."
But then I go, "Imagine
you're walking through the park
and you see a 7-year-old boy
singing 'New York State of Mind'
by Billy Joel.
You would feel like
a really bad person
if you didn't give him
all of your money."
-Yeah. And you would do this.
Who would take you there?
Just Dad or...?
-I -- We would --
I think our parents would go,
"Here's --" How much
was a bus back then?
I don't know.
"Here's a quarter for the bus."
This was in 1942,
I don't know. A quarter.
[ Laughter ]
-No. Probably $1.50, $2. Yeah.
-Take the bus.
We'll see you when you get back.
Let us know how it goes.
That kind of thing.
-Really?
-Yeah. We wanted to do it. Yeah.
-And you just
went and sang karaoke.
Did you have microphones?
No, you didn't have...
-We had microphones. We did.
Right?
-We did have microphones
and we tap danced.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-You tap danced?
-I don't see
anything funny about that.
No, no.
-That image? No.
-We actually have a clip
weirdly enough.
Here's AJR busking in
New York City back in 2005.
Take a look at this.
[ Shoes tapping ]
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's impressive.
-Is it? Thank you.
-That's impressive.
What was on your T-shirts there?
It says TB3.
-Oh, it's so embarrassing.
Do you want to say it?
-The band name was Tapping
Brothers to the Third Power.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Why didn't you...
Why didn't you keep that name
now?
The Tapping...
-That would have sounded good
coming out of your mouth.
"Now welcome Tapping..."
-Tapping Brothers to the Third
Power, ladies and gentlemen.
That's how we know them.
Yes.
I want to talk -- Your album
just came out at midnight.
How does it feel?
Congratulations,
and thank you
for doing our show.
-Thank you.
-It means a lot to us
that you're here.
The album title is called
"The Maybe Man."
What's the story
behind the title?
-We had a crazy couple
of years writing this album.
Some crazy family stuff
happened to us.
Our dad actually got sick
and passed away
during the making of this album.
When that happens,
it's really sad.
But it's also like, "Oh, my God,
I now know what matters
in life."
It's like all these
other opportunities
and choices
that you were worried about,
it's like, nope,
this is what matters in life.
It's friends, and it's
making art that you really love.
And I think that's a lot
what it's about.
It's like becoming 30 and being
in your 30s and realizing like,
oh, this is what I want
my life to be now.
-Gosh. Wow. That's tough.
Tough couple of years
dealing with this.
Well, he's got to be
proud of you guys.
-Oh, he was -- Yeah, he was
definitely our biggest fan.
I would say. He's the whole
reason we do this honestly.
He was such a music lover.
And he said "I want to give you
my knowledge of music
and go do something with it."
-At the end of every show,
I would always look forward to
looking out at him
in the audience,
because at the end of the show,
he would always stand up
and just go like this.
Yeah.
-That's a good dad.
That's a good supportive dad.
-There we go. Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Well, you announced that
you're going on an arena tour
with the album next year.
-Yes.
-And it included,
I couldn't help but notice,
a stop at Madison Square Garden.
And I was going to say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...to kids who were born
and raised in New York,
how does it feel to be playing
Madison Square Garden?
-I don't think I'm going
to really process
until we get up there.
We grew up like
five blocks downtown, literally
from Madison Square Garden.
So I'm hoping we can say --
maybe we can be the only people
ever to,
like, leave our house
and walk
to Madison Square Garden
to go to actually go play there.
Maybe that'd be...
-Yeah, you might be one of the
first people to ever do that.
-Yeah, but it's insane.
-And I got to say, I'm a fan of
"Yes, I'm a Mess."
-Thank you.
-Which you're performing
tonight?
-Yes, we are.
-On our show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The video, by the way,
turned out fantastic.
-Thank you.
-This is -- You were --
You were dressed
as a Times Square Elmo.
-I was, yes. That is me.
-Yeah.
Was that always
the plan of the video?
-No, that was not.
This is how it went.
There's a little message
in the beginning of the video
that says what happened.
What happened was we spent
a lot of money
on what was supposed
to be the music video.
We ended up finishing it
and it just didn't feel right.
Something in our gut was like,
"This is not going to work."
And the video was needed
like the next day.
And so we have to come up
with an idea
and I don't know
where it came from,
but I said me in an Elmo suit
in Times Square
trying to get tourists
to take photos with me.
[ Laughter ]
-Was it hard for people to take?
-It was nearly impossible, yes.
I think like maybe I got three
and I asked 500 people
to do this.
-It's a tough gig. I mean...
-It's -- So, what I did realize
was that the people,
the other dress-up figures,
are so good at this,
they're amazing.
And the reason I -- The way
I found out
how was I kind of started
to kind of assimilate with them.
And they -- So I went in, I was
like, "Hey, we're all Elmo."
And they started
to really befriend me.
They were like, "Oh, come on
in." They were gassing me up.
"That's a great Elmo costume.
Where'd you get it?"
And then I was getting
really excited.
And then two Minnie Mouse
costumes come over
and they go,
"Let us be in the video."
And they start doing a kick line
with me.
I'm like, "This is fun."
And then we stop
and they're like, "That was fun.
You know, it's really cold out.
And like, do you mind giving us,
you know, a little something?"
And I went, "Yeah."
And I kind of gave them all my
money because we're friends.
And then I walked away
and I was like,
"They're not my friends."
-No.
They're genius.
They are absolutely genius
at what they do.
Yeah. Here's a photo of you,
by the way.
Getting arrested
in Times Square.
Yeah. It's a very,
very fantastic video.
And you're going to perform it
for us later on tonight.
And congratulations.
The album is officially out.
"The Maybe Man," AJR.
It's available right now
and they're performing
for us after the break.
I'm so happy
to talk to you guys
and thank you again
for being here.
Come right back, everybody.
More "Tonight Show."